مسيرات وتظاهرات عمت كافه ارجاء الضفه
الغربيه بما فيها القدس المحتله حدادا
وغضبا وحزنا على اغتيال الشهيد القيادي
الشيخ صالح
العاروري ضباط
حبا من كافه الاعمار والاجيال ومن كل
الاطياف السياسيه شاركوا في هذه التظاهرات
يلي ما كبار يلي ماع كبار ودي ويها
للاعراض وخبيها للاعراس وخبيها للاعراس
وخبيها للاعراس هتافات وشعارات تطالب
بتصعيد المقاومه في الضفه
الغربيه شعارات تطالب ايضا بتوحيد الصف
الداخلي الذي كان وطالما نادى به الشهيد
صالح العرور ايضا الشعارات والتظاهرات
هنا تندد بكل المجازر التي يرتكبها
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تحديدا في قطاع
غزه التظاهرات والمسيرات جاءت في ظل
الاضراب العام والشامل الذي شل كافه مناحي
الحياه في الضفه الغربيه بما فيها القدس
المحتله الاضراب جاء للتعبير عن حاله من
الغضب والحزن والاستنكار لعمليه اختيال
الشهيد الشيخ صالح العاروري نعته الحركه
الاسيره ولكن ايضا اتهمته اسرائيل بكل
اجهزتها الامنيه بانه ايضا كان وراء
عمليات المقاومه الفلسطينيه تحديدا خلال
العامين الماضيين في الضفه الغربيه وتاكيد
على انه من اكثر الشخصيات الذي سعى لانهاء
الانقسام وتوحيد الصف الداخلي جفال بديري
الجزيره رام الله